[Music]
now i understand a big news in your life
you just moved into a new house
here in los angeles with your
bridesmaids co-star yeah lucas yes
there's you and matt lucas and in real
life
i mean
in real life you and matt have just
moved into a house together where is
this yeah because we played roommates so
well in bridesmaids we thought yeah
we'll do it for real yeah um except
instead of annoying kristen wiig we're
now annoying all the neighbors
nearby are you really annoying them well
i didn't think so but we got a letter in
the mailbox which i brought in today and
this is i heard about this and this
letter is real this is absolutely real
letter yeah yeah and so it was a little
bit disturbing this was in your mailbox
um because it's anonymous yeah for a
start
um and i'll just read it out to you in
how i think the person who wrote it
sounds like okay okay so
this is what they said
dear neighbor
i am living somewhere behind you
freaky
i am glad you are enjoying your new pool
and hot tub but i am trying to sleep
i can hear everything you say
even the british accents
say say i'm australian
obviously
anyway
is really this is genuinely creepy yeah
yeah
if you continue to make noise past 10
p.m i will call the cops
we have rules here in west hollywood
seriously
seriously was underlined
and stopped singing show tunes from
annie
that's he's doing a letter this is real
okay both of you are way too old to ever
be cast as child orphans
then it continues the sun will come out
tomorrow
yeah and so will the cops
and then instead of because it's
anonymous and then just at the end he
writes welcome to the neighborhood
see i don't know anything
you that's kind of i mean that's kind of
a little bit uh a little bit scary are
you gonna do
when did you get the note i am not
adding him on grinder no no
no
because apparently he can get arrested
yeah when did you uh find the note you
got it today
well no
we didn't find the mailbox key
for like a week so that letter was
sitting in a house in the box for a week
so have you been singing show tunes the
whole time yes but at least
at least we mix it up a bit like we've
been doing oklahoma
little shopahoras
fiddler on the roof
like
so i don't know
the neighbors do not enjoy it yeah i'm
just curious if it's going to get back
to this person who is anonymous that you
read the letter on television i'm
fascinated to hear if anything else
develops here will you keep us posted
yeah i will he goes to bed at 10 i don't
think he's seeing this
check it out online someone could wake
him up hey i heard something happened